[Applause]
just days ago millions of people took to
the streets across the world demanding
more action on climate change now
leaders gather at the United Nations in
New York where Luis Alfonso de Alba is
in charge of the climate summit his
message the Paris climate agreement is
no longer enough the biggest problem we
have is that we need to increase the
targets if we fulfill the commitments
that were made in Paris in 2015 we will
still be very much below what what is
needed the latest reports of the
scientific community tell us that we
need to double and in some cases to
triple what we have committed in Paris
but there's a problem with this ambition
far from doing more America one of the
world's biggest polluters is pulling out
of the Paris Accord can the world really
make the progress it needs to
while Donald Trump is in office no one
is telling us that they are going to
wait for the orders to move before they
do and the more the majority is moving
on this is not a problem for 2030 2050
but actions need to take place today
former United Nations secretary-general
ban ki-moon is optimistic big looters
like China and the UK are expected to
make new commitments and eventually he
thinks the US will fall into line I'm
sure that United said we'll have to
return to this because climate change
does not respect the national borders
the United State is just one of the
desert planet Earth the nature does not
negotiate with the human society but
there are other geopolitical headwinds
creating challenges the countries
gathering here at the United Nations in
New York for the climate summit have
been told that if they even want a
speaking slot they have to bring
enhanced commitments and
concrete plans there's a lot going on in
the world right now that might make that
more difficult like escalating trade
issues between China in the US tensions
with Iran and BRICS it the kind of
things that make countries focus on
their own needs and collective action on
anything much harder to achieve with the
eyes of the world on the United Nations
the pressure to do more on climate
change is building along with the cost
of doing nothing Hannah Thomas Peter Sky
News in New York